Florida Senator Marco Rubio is a
Republican member of the Foreign
Relations and intelligence committees
he's with us from Miami
senator good morning thank you so much
for joining us lots to talk about let's
start first with North Korea President
Trump has agreed to meet with the
world's most dangerous dictator without
preconditions what's your concern well I
actually think there are preconditions
and that is we're not going to get rid
of sanctions and we're going to continue
to move forward on the military
exercises with South Korea and if you're
still willing to meet despite that then
there's going to be a meeting so there
are preconditions and as far as what
this means I'm the fundamental question
is whether or not Kim jong-un will ever
accept not having nuclear weapons that's
at the core here because if he's not
willing to give up nuclear weapons and
the ability to strike the United States
then my sense is that this is basically
an effort to undermine international
sanctions by saying look I'm willing to
meet but in those meetings he makes
requests that you know we can never
accept like for example the u.s. leaving
South Korea and all of our troops
leaving our alliance there he knows
those conditions will never be met and
then he can turn to the international
community and say look I tried I'm a
reasonable person that Donald Trump and
the Americans are unreasonable in order
to undermine international sanctions and
also to undermine sort of international
support for a pre-emptive military
action so but it is clear to you that
the North Koreans have agreed to freeze
their capabilities before Trump sits
face to face with them well I think
that's kind of a misnomer because I
think in their mind that's the other
operative possibility is that they've
already decided that they have a
capability they have now they are now
confident that they have gone far enough
from their nuclear program that they can
enter negotiations from a position of
strength I've always believed that once
they believe they could strike the
United States or threaten to strike us
that they can then enter these
negotiations on equal footing there is
another possibility one that I think is
less likely but maybe part of this as
well and that is that there's tremendous
pressure among elites in North Korea
including diplomats around the world who
are required to bring back ill found
gains and basically bribery stealing
money etc that there's a lot of pressure
and rumblings among them about
discontent with the direction of the
country and Kim jong-un feels pressure
to so some level of progress
with regards to that audience so it's
obviously this is a very mysterious
regime and so we don't have the amount
of insight into them as we would some
other country so what you're describing
senator is a lot of traps and a lot of
difficult things to be negotiated so
give us often give us your assessment of
the Trump administration so far because
for a lot of people this looks like a
tremendous breakthrough for the Trump
administration the president his
strategy so assess that what got us here
and whether you think the administration
has the capability to run all those
traps you just outline well there's two
one or two things have gotten us here
either number one the kim jungeun is
supremely confident that he now has
leverage over the United States because
he believes we believe that he can
strike us or be he's under some level of
pressure that threatens his regime and
he feels like he needs to show the
elites in his country that he is in a
strong position and that he is willing
to do things and give people hope that
things are going to get better
I have no disagreement with her approach
I don't think we would be at this point
today had it not been for sticking with
sanctions and I think they are right to
argue that nothing is going to change
just because there's going to be a
meeting but so I think their pressure
has certainly brought us to this point
one way or another whether it's because
of internal pressure in North Korea
among elites or whether it's because Kim
jong-un now feels that he has no choice
but to engage and that he but but he's
comfortable and engaging because he has
nuclear weapons that he thinks he can
threaten the u.s. with senator let me
turn to domestic issues specifically one
related to your state and that is gun
legislation I know that you met with a
survivor a student from Stoneman Douglas
yesterday and we're reminded of course
of your town hall a month ago with those
students where you made news by saying
that you would be open it open to
raising the age of someone who can buy a
rifle from 18 to 21 you also said that
you would consider a limiting magazine
size and capacity have you made up your
mind on where you stand on those issues
well to be clear I said on
semi-automatic rifles I thinks
bolt-action hunting rifles and shotguns
and things of that nature is not what
we're talking about the state of Florida
has actually done that and I am willing
to support something that does that on
the magazine capacity it's a new issue
for me in terms of considering it
there's a lot of complexity there about
what the right size should be and so
forth so we're working through that but
here's been my approach
we the community's demanding action they
want something done every time one of
these things happen
nothing ever passes and the reason is we
put all our eggs in a basket that we
know doesn't have the votes to pass take
60 votes in the Senate a majority in the
house and a president that will sign it
so what I have focused on is phase one
of this effort is things that we can get
past that have broad bipartisan support
stop school violence act by Orrin Hatch
try and lie by Pat Toomey and Chris
Coons the fixed NICs bill senator Nelson
and I will be offering an incentive
program for states to pass what Florida
just passed a gun violence restraining
order I believe these things we can get
done there's consensus around them
that's step one these other more
contentious issues would be part of step
two but we don't get to step two unless
we show some momentum and some progress
with step one so that's what I've really
been focused on is phase one of this
effort and Senator just to be clear the
bill that the Florida Legislature just
passed it would raise the age for all
gun purchases from 18 to 21 yes or don't
you support that well I would prefer
that it not include shotguns and
bolt-action rifles but but let me be
clear about one thing for people that
are concerned about this it's not
possession so you can be 19 years old
and you know use your father's rifle to
go hunting you just can't be the owner
you can't go in and buy it yourself so
that's an important distinction is for
those out there that are concerned about
that
and we're running out of time but do you
expect the governor to sign that bill
that the Florida Legislature is okay I
believe he'll sign it today
senator Rubio thank you so much for
joining us this morning thank you